bayer eux
à la modification du code pénal il ya eu
lieu dans la loi du 30 juillet 2020
grâce à un travail en effet
particulièrement efficace à la fois des
députés mais aussi la sénatrice marie
mercier qui a été très impliquée sur le
sujet à nos côtés
vous l'avez également souligné dans la
dynamique a suivi nous avons entamé une
saisine à l'époque de ce qui s'appelait
encore le csa le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel à laquelle se sont joints
l'unaf ici présents et le cofrade le
cofrade qui représente plus de 50
associations de protection de l'enfance
récemment l'art comme a décidé de saisir
la justice
vous le savez nous attendons les
résultats courant du mois de mai si la
décision devait être positive cette
première mondiale ferait de la france un
pays pionnier dans la protection des
enfants face à la pornographie en ligne
et on verrait un signal fort aux
plateformes pour autant pour autant et
vous l'avez ok dans votre propos
liminaire les enjeux ne sont pas
seulement en ligne mais aussi sur le
terrain et en termes de régulation à la
fois des plates formes existantes mais
aussi des actions de prévention qui
peuvent être menées insité sur le
terrain destination des enfants et de la
communauté éducative
nous avons été assez suffisamment
critique et donc pour le souligner on a
été parmi les premiers à l'open a osé
afficher sur nos modules de formation et
d'accompagnement le mot pornographique a
longtemps dérangé dans le monde de la
formation y compris y compris des
professionnels de l'enfance est donc
aujourd'hui cette thématique et je pense
que ça ne vous surprendra pas l une des
thématiques parmi celles que nous
proposons qui nous est la plus réclamée
que ce soit par les parents mais aussi
par les professionnels de la protection
de l'enfance que ce soit des directions
d'être sociale à l'enfance mais aussi la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse qui
sont les témoins sur le terrain deux on
va dire des impacts de cette
consommation excessive de pornographie
qui peuvent inciter bon nombre d'enfants
on y viendra tout à l'heure à des
conduites à risques
comme je viens de le dire parents et
professionnels de l'enfance ont de plus
en plus en alerte sur ce sujet et leur
sol les sollicitations que nous recevons
par centaines illustre malheureusement
l'état de cette situation en france je
ne serais même tenté de dire que la
situation a plutôt tendance à se
dégrader se dégrader au regard des
sollicitations que nous recevons
désormais au niveau d'écoles primaires
pendant longtemps heureusement je dirais
serait tenté de dire heureusement ce
sujet n'était cantonné au collège et au
lycée désormais nous recevons des
sollicitations d'intervention en école
primaire de plus en plus nombreuses la
situation se dégrade également on
regarde des conduites à risques qui
découlent souvent de cette immersion
forcé dans cette bulle pornographiques
pour la plupart des jeunes et qui
impacte fortement comme toujours les
plus fragiles c'est toujours la même
chose en protection de l'enfance il
s'agit de parler évidemment des plus
fragiles et je parle également ici d'un
phénomène sur lequel nous sommes
particulièrement mobilisés et impliqués
à savoir la prostitution des mineurs qui
prend une ampleur phénoménale et
inquiétante dans notre pays
alors la situation se dégrade
malheureusement aussi au niveau du
climat scolaire de nombreux chefs
d'établissement nous alerte sur des
comportements inquiétants et des
difficultés relationnelles marqué et
souvent très genre et et la situation se
dégrade aussi et vous l'avez évoqué dans
les espaces numériques et notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux ou l'inéquité
fille/garçon s'illustre souvent par une
multiplication des violences numérique à
l'égard des jeunes filles qui va le plus
souvent jusqu'à l'envoi de photos
dénudées non sollicités qui émane de
garçons qui adresse ses photos de leur
sexe en érection parfois à tout va et
sans distinction aucune ce qui en l'état
est une véritable agression d'une
violence extrême et traumatisent de
nombreuses adolescentes
alors c'est bien les constats mais il
faut aussi et c'était l'objet de
discussions essayer de trouver des
solutions
c'est ce qu'on essaie également de
porter au sein de au sein de l'open
les solutions elles peuvent être de
plusieurs ordres je pense que la
régulation qui est en cours et qu'on a
évoqué et dont on attend la décision de
justice est un signal fort mais je pense
qu'il faut aller plus loin plus loin
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux alors je sais qu'en ce
moment des discussions et des signaux
forts sont envoyés au niveau 2 de
l'europe pour autant moi je suis
quelqu'un d'assez les pragmatiques et
j'attends de voir dans les faits ce
comment ça sera traduit en termes
d'applicabilité parents de parler par
les plateformes concernées parce que
malheureusement on a un triste exemple
en la matière le r j qui en termes de
protection de l'enfance est plutôt un
échec et donc j'attends de voir sur le
dans les faits comment ces directives en
cours deux décident de négociations vont
se retranscrire pour mieux protéger les
enfants au sein des réseaux sociaux je
vais prendre qu'un seul exemple si on
prend aujourd'hui un réseau social qui
est très dans l'actualité twitter sur
twitter est il normal acceptable en 2022
en quelques clics seulement on tombe sur
des vélos de pédophilie de
pédopornographie
de zoophilie de viol
c'est une question qui reste ouverte
pour ma part je vous douté de ma réponse
mais je trouve que on oublie souvent
aujourd'hui que certains réseaux sociaux
sont quand même sorte un petit peu du
lot et à chappes un plot au règles en
vigueur en tout cas celle qu'on tente de
mettre en place et pour moi twitter en
est malheureusement la triste
illustration
donc des enjeux de régulation comme je
le disais mais également des enjeux
techniques
vous avez évoqué dans votre propos le
contrôle parental je suppose que vous
faisiez allusion à la loi qui a été
discuté à l'assemblée nationale
également au sénat mise en place et
proposé par par bruno ce tuner
évidemment tout cela va dans le bon sens
notamment pour protéger les plus jeunes
mais à la question à la raison par don
de 2
de garder en tout cas
à l'esprit que les solutions techniques
ne peuvent pas être l'ensemble des
solutions surtout que le contrôle
parental on l'a bien vu en france a
souvent été présenté à tort comme étant
une espèce de solution miracle aux
parents qui avait un peu l'impression
qu'à partir du moment où on installer et
c'était d'ailleurs malheureusement les
campagnes de communication qui étaient
mises en place par les pouvoirs publics
les parents avaient souvent l'impression
qu'une fois que ces outils étaient
installés il pouvait plus rien arriver à
leurs enfants un dos au même titre que
si on installe une ceinture de sécurité
en voiture on sait très bien qu'elle
n'empêche pas pour autant d'avoir des
accidents et donc il essaie vraiment
nous les écueils principaux qu'on a mis
en examen lors de nos auditions avec
bruno suder et au sénat c'est d'être
très vigilants sur les sur les campagnes
de communication qui peut en découler de
cette loi pour pas faire de fausses
promesses aux parents et ne pas tomber
dans le piège dans lequel on est tombés
pendant de nombreuses années à savoir
venir également engendré dé facto sur le
terrain on l'a vu des parents qui
avaient l'impression que le job était
fait à partir du moment les outils
étaient déployés dans la famille
et je rappelle aussi mais ça vous en
douter qu'en termes d'enjeux éducatif
tout cela doit se passer en discussion
l'étude que nous avons publié avec
l'unaf au mois de février dernier sur
l'usagé du numérique dans les familles
en france
relaté notamment quelqu'un chiffres
inquiétants déjà le chiffre inquiétant
du de la feb l'installation de ces
dispositifs de contrôles parentaux et
puis un autre chiffre inquiétant qui
démontre selon nous l'angoissent
parental par rapport à tous ces sujets à
savoir plus de 40% des familles en
france qui installe un logiciel espion
sur le téléphone de leurs enfants quand
je parle de logiciels espions je parle
de logiciels qui permettent de d'écouté
d'espionner les conversations
d'avoir accès au répertoire du téléphone
d'avoir accès à la photothèque de
surveiller les messages téléphoniques et
ses stars donc quelque chose d'assez
intrusif et qu'il faut interpréter comme
étant un message une extrême inquiétude
des parents sur ces sujets
donc j'ai évoqué les enjeux de
régulation les enjeux techniques est
évidemment un volet qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur les enjeux
éducatifs
là je pense qu'il faut aussi être lucide
se poser la question pour laquelle
pourquoi certains jeunes vont chercher
ses contenus notamment les adolescents
et la réponse est assez simple ça fait
trois décennies en france que rencontre
un échec cuisant de l'éducation sexuelle
et qu'il est grand temps de faire
évoluer les choses dans le bon sens
peut-être même d'ailleurs et c'est à ça
se discute je sais que vous avez
auditionné ovidie avec qui je travaille
régulièrement on partage plutôt ce point
de vue peut-être même retiré le mot
affectif de l'éducation sexuelle parce
que je pense aujourd'hui qu'elle peut
bloquer certains jeunes qui nous
envoient des messages un petit peu
autour de cette dichotomie giec fixé
suel vie affective dont il faut aussi
qu'il faut aussi entendre et écouter ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas faire
passer des messages de prévention mais
en terme d'affichage pour séduire les
jeunes en termes de politiques de
prévention me semble-t-il il faut aussi
entendre qu'ils nous disent
aimer aussi me semble-t-il le plus
important c'est ça ça concerne tous les
sujets je pense que les mets mes
collègues présents sur la table
partageront ce constat qu'ont ceux qu'on
soit vraiment dans une logique de
prévention primaire aujourd'hui en tant
qu'opérateur sur le terrain on passe
notre temps à jouer les sapeurs pompiers
on arrive dans des établissements
scolaires ou dans des endroits typé jjd
foyer de l'aide sociale à l'enfance oui
c'est passé parfois des choses très
traumatiques pour les équipes ou pour
les parents comment voulez-vous un
sifflet de la réflexion dans des espaces
d'émotion tels que on est juste là à
éteindre un peu les incendies on permet
pas d'être dans une logique de
prévention primaire comme on le
souhaiterait d'où vraisemblablement
l'enjeu pouvoir démarrer ses actions de
prévention éducative dès la maternelle
de toute évidence
donc en jeu de lutter contre ce piège de
ces espaces d'émotion et de revenir à la
prévention que le primaire mais aussi
d'impliquer selon nous l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative
et de pas se contenter uniquement de
faire la prévention autour des enfants
et des adolescents parce que évidemment
les parents la communauté éducative les
professionnels qui gravitent autour des
enfants et des adolescents sont souvent
perdus eux aussi face à des pratiques
qu'ils ont à gérer au quotidien et qui
sont souvent des catastrophes qu'il faut
le dire est qu'ils méritent de pouvoir
discuter tous ensemble de manière
constructive positive la meilleure
manière d'accompagner ces jeunes autour
de ces nouvelles conduites
c'est ce que nous avons essayé de faire
d'ailleurs avec ovi dit je pense qu'elle
vous en a peut-être parlé on a
on dans le département de la charente
pendant 18 mois travaillés à la en lien
avec la délégation aux droits des femmes
sur place qui nous a missionné pour à la
fois allé voir les enfants mais aussi
les parents et l'ensemble des
professionnels pour tout simplement
ouvrir des espaces de discussion autour
de ce sujet qui est devenu complètement
tabou dans l'enceinte des établissements
scolaires aujourd'hui la réalité que
vivent la plupart des adolescents en
france et que quand on parle
d'homosexualité
vous avez neuf adultes sur dix qui
tourne les talons et s'en voit en
courant et l'enjeu est vraiment de
pouvoir remettre des sujets des espaces
de discussions apaisées au sein des
établissements scolaires et eon et on
rencontre régulièrement des initiatives
portées par des infirmières notamment
des assistantes sociales qui font un
travail formidable souvent dont on ne
parle que trop peu et qui portent à bout
de bras souvent même contre l'avis de
leur direction du rectorat des espaces
qu'elle recréer au sein des
établissements scolaires et qui font un
travail du coup formidable pour aborder
et et son a6 eu alité de manière apaisée
et dans une vraie logique de prévention
pour le coup
et puis également je pense que là je
vais insister sur des aspects forme mais
je pense qu'au niveau font aujourd'hui
et vous l'avez très bien évoqué nous
c'est également ce qu'on constate dans
certaines conduites à risques dans les
espaces numériques il devient me
semble-t-il assez compliqué de procéder
à une dichotomie entre éducation aux
médias et éducation à la sexualité
les deux sont désormais me semble t'il
intimement liés à l'heure où les
influenceurs les influences euse adopte
pour certains certaines des
comportements hyper sexualisée dans ces
espaces numériques échappe à tout
contrôle on voit bien on voit bien les
points de bascule qui s'opère chez
certains jeunes et notamment l'émergence
de nouvelles pratiques et nouvelle
plateforme de type only fans smim et
c'est en france qu'ils sont très
incitatif pour certains et certaines
jeunes en difficulté ou fragiles et on
voit bien que la perméabilité entre le
monde de l'influent sur les réseaux
sociaux et l'apparition de ces nouvelles
plateformes très centré sur la vente de
deux vidéos et de photos à caractère
sexuel est vraiment très inquiétante est
très problématique
donc voilà pour ce pour ce point sur
l'éducation aux médias évidemment les
sujets qui sont jamais abordées comme le
rapport au corps
la remise en question de l'intimité et
le respect de l'altérité doivent être au
coeur de nous semble-t-il de ces
nouveaux combats éducatifs c'est
d'ailleurs ce que l'on essayé aussi de
faire à l'open et menacent pas plus tard
que la semaine dernière nous intervenons
à la demande du daf à rodez ou dans le
cadre du printemps du numérique animé
par cette huile daf 300 jeunes étaient
réunis dans l'après midi face à nous
pour essayer d'entamer un dialogue
autour de ces questions et je peux vous
assurer que quand vous sortez de ces
deux heures de débat avec ses 300
lycéens vous voyez vraiment la
différence entre les questions que se
posent les filles les questions souvent
très immature qui concerne la gente
masculine et les difficultés de dialogue
entre êtres compréhension autour de ces
sujets entre entre filles et garçons ce
qui provient la nécessité de rouvrir des
espaces de discussions apaisées ce qu'on
a c'est ce qu'on essaie modestement de
faire et puis je pense également ça sera
la fin de mon propos ne pas oublier que
le pire vient souvent d'internet mais
les des choses des initiatives des ovnis
audiovisuel existe aussi dans ces
espaces numériques et je pense que
encourager la création et l'organisation
d'un contre discours qui pourrait se
déployer sur les réseaux sociaux c'est à
dire là où sont les jeunes ce que
certaines femmes jeunes femmes et c'est
d'ailleurs d'entreprendre souvent à
leurs dépens je pense à certaines un
strike instagram euse qui animent des
comptes formidable du type tu as joué et
c'est qu'ils sont souvent d'ailleurs
souvent shadowbane et comme on dit
instagram puisqu'elles seront bloquées
leurs comptes régulièrement
encourager ce type de contre discours
peut aussi permettre de toucher plus en
profondeur les jeunes parce que c'est
aussi aller là où ils sont et ne pas
oublier qu'aujourd'hui s'informent
essentiellement par ses espaces
numériques est également je pense
peut-être la facilitation
l'identification des ressources de
qualité qui existent pourquoi pas une
labellisation je ne sais pas quelque
chose d'assez à la mode est en tout cas
voilà encourager un contre discours avec
des contenus de qualité pour
déconstruire les stéréotypes véhiculés
par la pornographie et libérer la parole
des jeunes qui en sont particulièrement
demandeur voilà
merci beaucoup monsieur rohmer pour la
qualité des pistes déjà que vous lancez
et la qualité des propositions je vais
immédiatement passé la parole à olivier
gérard votre voisin est donc qui
intervient au titre de l'unaf
merci merci beaucoup madame billaut
merci beaucoup à la délégation aux
droits des femmes de me donner
l'occasion de m'exprimer donc thomas
rohmer a exprimé un certain nombre de
2.2 constat que nous partageons soit
l'open est minable donc je n'y
reviendrai pas si ce n'est pour dire
qu'effectivement
je pense qu'il est important d'assister
sur sur ce point de des sentiments d'une
dégradation de la situation c'est vrai
qu'on est on est dans un jeu par un peu
dans un paradoxe où on voit un certain
nombre de dispositifs de loi qui se met
en place d'actions de communication des
pouvoirs publics mais aussi nous sur le
terrain des associations pour
accompagner les publics et leur montrer
qu'il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
vous lui et en même temps ce sentiment
que
de la situation ne s'est pas améliorée
que l'accès et au contenu pornographique
est toujours aussi facile aussi simple
que ce soit volontaire ou involontaire
comme vous l'avez exprimé au tout début
et finalement en tout cas du côté des
parents non seulement des demandes
d'être accompagnés mais surtout une
forme une forme d'incompréhension ou
certains parents se demande si
finalement la protection des mineurs ou
la lutte contre ces violences numérique
et est finalement pas pas vraiment
considéré et qu' il y aurait une forme
de sacrifice de ces enjeux face à
d'autres enjeux peut-être économique
de fatalité aussi un sentiment de
fatalité comme si les dés étaient lancés
les choses étaient faites voilà nokia
sur le terrain aussi ce questionnement
et donc il est important aujourd'hui de
dalles et sans doute au delà de ce qui a
été de ce qui a déjà été mis en place et
de pouvoir véritablement apporter une
réponse pour montrer et ça a été dit par
papa le par le gouvernement ça a été dit
par le président de la république il ya
une volonté véritablement de lutter
contre ce fléau mais on a le sentiment
que le la transformation entre cette
volonté et la mise en place
et un impact plutôt sur l'accès des
mineurs n'a pas lieu et ça c'est quand
même une préoccupation alors
je voulais quand même également
compléter sur constat par un certain
nombre de deux chiffres qui sont issus
de l'étude qu'on a réalisé avec avec
l'open et qui moi me semblait
intéressant c'est qu'effectivement il ya
beaucoup de parents qui s'interrogent et
en même temps quand on quand on creuse
un petit peu et quand on l'a questionné
les parents sur finalement les risques
numériques ou les risques ce qui a
inquiété les parents on constate que
bien que juste que parfois la question
de la pornographie
n'est peut-être pas suffisamment pris en
compte par par les parents on a regardé
la question des risques auxquels est
exposé les enfants sur ceux sur internet
ou dans les univers numériques et on
s'aperçoit finalement que la
pornographie n'apparaît qu'en dixième
position avec seulement trois quarts des
parents qui qui nous disent que le
numérique peut exposer à la pornographie
ce qui ce qui montre qu'un pour un quart
des parents là il s'agit même pas savoir
si leurs propres enfants étaient exposés
à la pornographie mais simplement est ce
que le le numérique peut exposer la
pornographie pour trois cars 2 les trois
quarts d'un quart des parents par dont
25%
il n'y a pas de d'exposition à la
pornographie possible sur le numérique
ce qui montre quand même qu'il ya une
méconnaissance et une incompréhension
pour certains parents de ces univers
numérique et lorsqu'on leur demande ce
qu'ils ce qui les inquiète le plus eh
bien il ya seulement 44% des parents qui
disent être inquiété
20 kg et 2 du risque pornographie pour
l'enfant c'est à dire la seule par an
sur deux
on voit que il ya là véritablement un
enjeu n en jeu quand même de faire qu'on
de faire prendre conscience aux parents
qu'il ya aujourd'hui cette problématique
de la de la pornographie
est sans doute en termes de
communication même si beaucoup de choses
ont été faites
bonjour madame on signale même si un
certain nombre de
d'actions ont été menées il ya sans
doute des des pistes aussi de majeur de
communication pour pour vraiment faire
prendre conscience aux parents qu'il ya
qu'il ya un enjeu pornographiques
voilà ça c'était un chiffre qui moi me
semblait qu'il me semblait important de
mettre en avant
alors ensuite sur sur les sur les
propositions puisque c'était l'objet de
la table ronde là encore sa surprise je
pense que les trois axes les trois
piliers qui ont été évoqués tout à
l'heure nous les partageons à la fois il
ya un enjeu d'agir en termes de
dispositions juridiques en termes de
renforcement des des solutions
techniques et aussi en termes de
prévention et d'éducation donc ces trois
piliers qui qui préside
finalement à vos actions qu'on peut
mener à lui neuf sont évidemment hâtives
et de manière à la fois cohérente et
combiné pour tendre une efficacité alors
sur la réglementation on est on est
comme on est comme l'open en attente de
la décision du tribunal qui est qui
interviendra mi mai pour nous c'est un
enjeu évidemment extrêmement important
c'est important parce que effectivement
comme l'a dit tomasz
elle signale un signal fort mais ça
c'est pour nous quelque chose
d'important même si évidemment
et vous l'avez dit en introduction et on
constate sur le terrain dont l'accès à
la pornographie ne passe pas seulement
par les sites internet des jets
et d'études que vous évoquez en
introduction le rappelle si besoin
aujourd'hui l'accès des jeunes des 15 17
ans pour le coup puisque l'étude portait
sur les 15 17 ans rappelle que si le 40%
des jeunes accèdent au contenu
pornographique par des sites internet
dédiés il n'en demeure pas moins que
près de trois enfants sur 10 accède via
les réseaux sociaux et thomas l'a
rappelé sur twitter mais ça concerne
également d'autres d'autres réseaux
sociaux
l'étude rappelle également que si on
additionne finalement les applications
de type messagerie et des emails on a
aussi un tiers des jeunes de 15 à 17 ans
qui
sont mis face à des contenus
pornographiques
directement entre pères et entre jeunes
et ça c'est quelque chose aussi
d'importants à a rappelé et là ça
renvoie bien à l'idée de renforcer les
les actions d'éducation et de prévention
et qu'on voit bien que ce n'est pas ça
n'est pas seulement des solutions
jouy dit good technology qui pourront
qui pourront faire face à sète à ces
pratiques là qui sont qui sont
importantes
moi me semblait important dans cette
étude
également de
noter un chiffre qui moi me semblait
extrêmement important c'était dans les
pratiques et la consommation des jeunes
de contenu pornographique c'était
d'écart qu'on pouvait constater entre
les pratiques moyenne et les pratiques
mais jeunes et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important parce que ça
montre aussi que l'on a une part
importante de ces jeunes qui sont
effectivement sion or consommation
extrêmement excessive extrêmement
importante et que c'est vrai qu'on
constate que ce soit des pratiques en
termes de temps passé par mois ou deux
du moment où kelly ciotat les pour la
dernière fois
on est choix sur 24 24 jours on
s'aperçoit qu'on a aussi nommé diane
beaucoup plus basse ce qui montre qu'on
a quand même une grosse partie de ces
jeunes qui vont une manière très
importante et quasi quotidiennement et
ça c'est quelque chose aussi aussi
d'importants ce qui est important aussi
à noter dans cette étude assez
intéressante c'est qu'elle rappelle
qu'on a sur des solutions des
dispositifs techniques notamment les vpn
on a un taux de notoriété 40% de ces
dispositifs chez les jeunes ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que quels que soient
les dispositifs légaux qui seront mis en
place on sait qu'on a aujourd'hui des
solutions techniques qui pourront
permettre de les contourner que les
solutions techniques là sont connus de
tous cas une notoriété de 40% de mémoire
chantier 9% des jeunes qui
10 savoir les utiliser 30% qui connaît
ce qui ne les ont pas encore utilisé
mais qui seront sans doute assez à
l'aise au tout cas trouveront assez
facilement là la manière de les utiliser
donc là c'est aussi un aspect important
qui à mon sens se renvoient également
sur l'enjeu éducatif parce que là à
nouveau la question allait bien de faire
comprendre aussi de travailler avec
c'est avec ces jeunes sur le pourquoi
est ce qu'on met en place des
dispositifs techniques et pourquoi est
ce que ces solutions qui permettent de
les contourner ne sont pas forcément à
utiliser voilà travailler sur ces
aspects là c'est aussi important et
c'est ce que l'étude met en avant
donc ça c'était le premier point sur sur
les aspects réglementaires liées et 10e
au site je partage totalement et je
l'avais noté également dans mes propos
cette question des réseaux sociaux c'est
donc 30% des jeunes aujourd'hui disent
consulter des contenus pornographiques
sur sur les réseaux sociaux alors on est
sur les 15 17 ans mais dans l'étude
qu'on avait mené on rappeler quand même
que entre 7 et 10 ans
un enfant sur deux dispose et déjà d un
compte sur un réseau social est en cours
on avait plutôt doux en fait donc on a
une moyenne assez importante et donc on
voit bien que même si théoriquement ces
réseaux sociaux sont
interdits avant avant 13 ans il de hergé
comme le dit thomas prévoyait
notamment
une consentement du mineur et des
parents entre 13 et 15 ans pour la
france 13 et 16 ans dans les textes et
13 et 15 ans en france on constate
qu'aujourd'hui presque quatre ans après
le rhdp dit les choses n'ont pas
véritablement évolué qu'aujourd'hui les
réseaux sociaux la plupart des réseaux
sociaux ne met pas en place de dix
possibles de vérification d'âge etc on
est donc dans un système où après quatre
ans de travaux de discussions de
réflexions
les choses n'ont pas évolué et ça c'est
quand même quelque chose qui qui est
inacceptable qui est difficile aussi sur
le terrain auprès des parents notamment
à expliquer parce que d'à côté on
rappelle les textes on rappelle la loi
et puis de l'autre on constate que les
choses n'ont pas été mis en place alors
on nous annonce alors on sait que des
dispositifs et sondages et ça soulève un
certain nombre de questions de
problématiques ce n'est pas des choses
simples mais en même temps on est quand
même dans un univers de technologie un
univers numérique et nous pensons que
qui doit être possible de trouver des
systèmes qui permettent de protéger les
enfants d'éviter un accès des plus
jeunes aux réseaux sociaux sans aucun
consentement des parents tout en
garantissant un certain nombre de de
respect de principes liés aux données
personnelles dit à la vie privée ni à la
liberté aussi de navigation notamment
des adultes donc voilà ça c'est pour
nous un point un point d' alerte parce
que il y a là aussi un enjeu extrêmement
important pour pour les parents et pour
et pour les pour les familles alors sur
les solutions techniques et de contrôle
parental
on a évoqué la loi de gounod stud heures
je vais grandir un certain nombre de
choses que thomas dit je suis désolée
mais nous partageons un certain nombre
d'éléments donc effectivement nous
avions enfin nous avons lors des
auditions soutenue évidemment ce ce
dispositif pour nous c'est une brique
supplémentaire une pierre supplémentaire
notamment pour pour les plus jeunes
parce que on sait que les dispositifs de
contrôles parentaux sont sans doute plus
pertinent lorsque les enfants sont plus
jeunes pour éviter que les enfants
tombent notamment sur des contenus de
manière involontaire que c'est
évidemment des solutions des dispositifs
plus complexe lorsqu'on est avec des pré
ados des adolescents ou les ailes il ya
aussi des enjeux de d'autonomie de
l'enfant de liberté d'intimité l'enfant
qui doit pouvoir peut-être plus
facilement accéder à des contenus en
ligne sans que cela se fasse
nécessairement avec le consentement et
l'accord des paroles soi même que les
parents soient au courant de tout ce
qu'il fait et thomas a évoqué les
disputent le contrôle c'est pour nous
important de 2,2 de rappeler que cette
notion même de contrôle parental peut
créer une confusion une idée c'est pas
forcément de tout contrôler et de
surveiller ou de cliquer puisque vous
avez évoqué le mot c'est le passé l'idée
c'est bien ou pas à la fois de protéger
les enfants de les accompagner de les
accompagner vers l'autonomie et c'est
vrai que on constate parfois une espèce
de de
deux parents qui vont plutôt vers cette
logique de surveillance permanente et ça
c'est pour nous quelque chose quelque
chose d'important donc sous le contrôle
parental oui c'est une brique
supplémentaire après effectivement il ya
de véritables enjeux en jeu et du
éducatif et d'accompagnement à la bonne
utilisation de ces outils de contrôle
parental
d'abord effectivement ça a été dit ça
n'est pas des solutions ce n'est pas des
systèmes qui vont qui ont solutionné
tous tous les enjeux qui vont à des
solutions miracles
et ça c'est important de ne pas décider
doute l'esprit des parents et on l'a vu
par le parle par le passé on le voit sur
le terrain lorsque vous parlez avec des
parents et que vous évoquez la manière
dont ils s'accompagnent les enfants vous
avez régulièrement des parents qui vous
disent mais j'ai installé une solution
de contrôle parental c'est bon voilà
tout et tout est fait c'est parfait il
faut pas laisser de doute sur le fait
que non le contrôle parental
ne s'excusera ne sécurisera jamais à
100% les enfants ou la vue de l'étude
allemande et on le sait il ya d'autres
manières de
d'accéder ou à la pornographie qui ne
seront pas sécurisé par les outils de
contrôle parental et le contrôle
parental ne doit absolument pas se
substituer à l'accompagnement et au
dialogue parentale et ça c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement important
rappelé également et ça c'est aussi
important c'est que l'utilisation de ces
outils
de contrôle parental suppose pour être
efficace le plus efficace possible
suppose d'être bien paramétrer d'être
adapté aux pratiques de l'enfant aux
pratiques familiales aussi ça supposons
que les parents soient en capacité de
s'approprier ces outils et ça ça suppose
évidemment d'accompagner les parents à
cette appropriation
et ça c'est pour nous un enjeu
extrêmement importante dans la suite
delà de cette disposition c'est à dire
que proposer aux parents une activation
lorsqu'on
utilise pour la première fois les des
outils numériques situ qui est une bonne
chose mais il faut évidemment que les
parents soient dans le même temps
accompagné pour comprendre à la fois ce
que sont ces outils et comment les
utiliser comme les paramétrer comment
les adapter à l'âge des enfants et
regardons toujours un peu à l'esprit que
ça n'est jamais la solution miracle et
qu'ils doivent être au service des
parents et qui ne doivent pas remplacer
des parents et ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important
qui est valable dans le cas de l'accès à
la pornographie mais qui est valable
aussi sur d'autres d'autres pratiques
numériques qui peuvent être concernés
par ces outils de contrôles parentaux
donc voilà pour ces dispositifs de
contrôles parentaux
il y as sans doute
effectivement une amélioration à faire
en terme d' usage par un certain de
parents mais
il faut quand même garder à l'esprit que
ça suppose
véritablement d'accompagner notamment
les parents éloignés aussi du nu il faut
pas l'oublier ça n'a pas encore été
évoquée mais n'oublions pas qu'on ait
aussi dans un contexte où même si on a
des parents des jeunes parents
aujourd'hui ou du coup du moins des
parents de jeunes enfants parce que ça
peut départ en moins jeunes des parents
de jeunes enfants même si on baigne tous
les univers numériques pour autant là
quand même une partie de la population
qui est en difficulté avec des outils
numériques qui peuvent être des jeux des
parents de jeunes enfants il faut pas
les oublier c'est pour ça que
il est important toujours de t'avoir
cette logique d'accompagnement y compris
sur les dispositifs techniques
je je je viens sur le troisième point
donc sur les piliers des éducatifs
donc on l'a vu on l'a dit et je lui ai
dit à plusieurs reprises il ya
véritablement un enjeu un enjeu éducatif
l'idée c'est véritablement de pouvoir
sur cette question de la de la
pornographie à la fois accompagné les
enfants mais aussi accompagner les
professionnels thomas l'a évoqué et les
parents
alors évidemment on sait que pour nous
l'idée c'est pas forcément que cette
question de la pornographie ou de cet
espace de discussion autour des enjeux
de la pornographie se fasse en famille
la question elle se pose pas de de cette
manière mais il est important quand même
que les parents
soient bien conscients de ce risque et
il soit bien conscient de ce qu'il ya
derrière ce sourire c'est à dire
pourquoi est ce que les enfants
souhaitent
accéder à des contenus pornographiques
ces questions autour de la sexualité ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
c'est quelque chose que les enfants des
questions que les enfants se posent et y
les parents doivent avoir conscience que
ces questions là elles vont se poser
pour les enfants alors ça veut pas dire
que dès ce sont les parents qui ne doit
forcément aborder ces sujets ça n'est
simple ça n'est pas forcément des sujets
faciles et pour avoir une adolescente à
la maison je sais que c'est pas un sujet
simple c'est pas un sujet facile
j'ai fait le choix mois plus tôt d'en
parler mais je peux concevoir que
d'autres parents n'est pas cette cette
volonté là mais en revanche il faut que
les parents puissent éventuellement
orienté guider leurs enfants vers des
ressources vers des lieux euros soit
vers des outils thomas évoqué un certain
nombre de 2,2 de ressources en ligne qui
sont qui sont quand même assez
incroyable assez bien fait et les
parents pourraient parfaitement aussi
invité ou reconnaître ses outils ses
ressources et un site et pourquoi pas
dès les jeunes à aller les consulter à
les regarder ses vidéos et aussi les
orienter vers un verde verdelho 60 pour
nous il ya un enjeu de parentalité qui
est quand même qui est assez important
et vous donc continuer à impliquer les
parents dans cet ordre dans cette
démarche mais dans une démarche aussi
beaucoup plus large c'est à dire qu'on
ne peut pas déconnecter cette question à
la fois de l'éducation aux médias mais
plus généralement sous de compréhension
des enjeux numériques
on évoquait tout à l'heure
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le fait que
l'utilisation fait l'accès au contenu
pornographique passer par les réseaux
sociaux passés par le les échanges de
contenus entre entre jeunes et on sait
que c'est souvent via le smartphone et
téléphones portables on le rappelle
chaque fois mais on a aujourd'hui en
france un tout premier l'équipement en
téléphones portables qui est inférieur à
10 ans donc ça on voit bien qu'il l'a
souvent des parents qui ont équipé leurs
enfants à un six sept huit ans d'un
téléphone portable sans pour autant
derrière les accompagner peut-être parce
que unis ne voit pas au départ de risque
il voit plutôt ce que peut apporter le
téléphone portable parfois d d d
intérêts qui sont réelles parfois qui
sont un peu plus fantasmer mais en tout
état de cause n'y a pas forcément
d'accompagnement à ses usages du
téléphone portable et on voit bien que
souvent on a des enfants qui vont
accéder à ces équipements sans
accompagnement et pour nous c'est
souvent travaillé sur cette question de
prévention du risque
pornographiques c'est aussi travailler
plus généralement sur l'accompagnement
et la parentalité numérique c'est-à-dire
accompagner les parents à comprendre les
enjeux numériques dont les enjeux de
pornographique et qui renvoie finalement
à cette question
d'encadrement plus générale des
pratiques numériques par par les enfants
et on ne peut pas déconnecter c'est ces
deux aspects dans l'ensemble des actions
que nous menons à l'unr ce soit en ligne
à travers sa tombe de ressources ou sur
sur le terrain on essaye à la fois de
proposer des ressources qui porte sur
ces questions de la pornographie de
l'éveil amoureux des pratiques à risque
des pratiques numériques des enfants
mais aussi des questions plus générales
de l'utilisation de l'accompagnement au
bon usage des outils numériques des
questions autour d'eux
à quel âge et comment et pourquoi est ce
qu'on doit équiper son enfant d'un
téléphone portable on essaye
véritablement d'avoir une approche un
peu global est de travailler aussi avec
des structures est-ce qu'on cinq toiles
a évoqué tout à l'heure le fait par
exemple qu'il soit intervenu de dalida
est-ce que sur un certain nombre de
thématiques précises on va plutôt
orienté vers les structures de terrain
qui existent donc donc voilà donc pour
nous il y avait également un ange de 2,2
parentalité un enjeu à faire connaître à
faire connaître ses ressources je lui
disais tout à l'heure aussi avec une
vigilance importante sur les parents
éloignés du numérique est ce assez pour
nous quelque chose d'important parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a parfois eu le réflexe
de
d'être dans une logique d'éducation aux
enjeux numériques par le numérique et on
oublie souvent que pour beaucoup de
parents la solution elle passe pas
uniquement par part s'est exclamé
quelque part comme pour pour les jeunes
c'est important aussi les changes
l'interaction le fait de rencontrer
d'autres adultes et de pouvoir échanger
un peu plus un peu plus librement sur
sur ces problématiques
donc voilà
évidemment et c'est quand même un point
important où on voit qu'on est face à un
enjeu un enjeu
de politique publique est extrêmement
important il est aussi important que les
moyens financiers soient soient adaptés
à la hauteur des enjeux et ça pour pour
les associations qui interviennent sur
le terrain c'est quand même c'est quand
même un aspect important il faut
véritablement que les politiques
publiques suivent dans l'accompagnement
des notamment des associations
d'un dernier point mais je vais pas être
très très long parce que thomas l'alleud
en parle bien mieux que moi c'est
évidemment on est aussi
favorable à ce que les jeunes puissent
s'exprimer plus abordé les espaces qu'il
évoquait ces espaces de
discussion n'est ce pas saoulé les
jeunes puissent librement poser des
questions librement s'exprimer sont
extrêmement importants on a nous
quelques-uns à quelques associations et
quelques unes à qui développe des
notamment des actions à destination des
jeunes autour des questions relatives à
l'ordre à la vie affective relationnelle
et sexuelle des fameuses et vars
et on partage le constat qui a été fait
c'est qu'effectivement
ces dix sujets qui sont
parfois difficiles à porter notamment
dans les établissements scolaires il y a
encore des points de blocage
et c'est assez compliqué de développer
ses actions alors on essaye de les
organiser dans d'autres lieux avec
d'autres partenaires mais il me semble
que effectivement le l'école doit aussi
être un lieu qui doit s'ouvrir à c'est
assez problématique là donc je partage
ce qui a été dit et dernier point je
pense qu'il ya aussi la à nouveau un
effort de
communication des ressources à
destination des jeunes autour de ces
problématiques qui a beaucoup de choses
qui ont déjà été fait mais on a aussi un
certain nombre de deux jeunes d'ados qui
ou de prêts à nous mêmes qui n'ont pas
connaissance de ces ressources et là il
ya un enjeu de communication assez
important
voilà pour
pour premier tour de table et des propos
liminaires
merci monsieur gérard genre profite
puisque j'ai la parole pour saluer
l'arrivée de laurence rossignol qui
rapportera mes côtés avec deux autres
porteurs comme je le disais dans mon
propos liminaire salue la présence de
bruno glace sénateurs nous avons
également des sénatrices qui sont
connectés avec victoire jasmin pour la
guadeloupe annick jacquemet et dominique
vais rien et nous avions marie pierre
monnier qui étaient avec nous également
en salle voilà donc merci pour votre
intervention monsieur gérard qui coupent
complète justement l'intervention de
monsieur rohmer avec évidemment ce
couple éducation numérique éducation à
la sexualité qui semble très très liés
et qu'il va falloir il va falloir s'y
attaquer je vais céder la parole
troisième intervenant qui monsieur
gordon choisel président de innocence et
je vous cède immédiatement la parole
charles dessus merci mme la présidente
notre association s'intéresse
spécifiquement à la lutte contre
l'exposition involontaire c'est à dire
l'exposition qui n'est pas recherché et
qui dans bien des cas est la première
exposition
cette exposition a lieu essentiellement
sur des sites ou non pornographique
donc soit des sites de streaming par
exemple avec des fenêtres pop up mais
également via des smartphones grâce aux
messageries instantanées aux différentes
applications qui permettent de
transférer des images entre amis est
tout simplement dans la cour de
récréation comme l'évoquait l'instant
olivier la diffusion du téléphone
portable dans les cours de récréation
fait que dès l'école primaire il suffit
qu un des camarades de votre enfant et
un téléphone portable pour que votre
enfant ait accès au contenu de ce
téléphone portable
les chiffres que vous évoquez sont
inquiétants et je crois qu'il faut
garder à l'esprit qu'ils sont assez
optimistes par rapport à la réalité du
terrain olivier thomas rappelait qu'il y
à une aggravation de la situation je me
souviens que lorsque nous avions animé
avec olivier des réunions pour la
création du site je protège mon enfant
point gouv.fr l'ensemble des acteurs
associatifs présents s'accordaient à
dire que la première exposition avait
lieu aux primaires aux alentours de
l'âge de 8 ans et que
dans l'ensemble un enfant sur deux avait
déjà eu accès à du contenu
pornographique
en primaire les différents sondages nous
donnent un premier regard mais gardant à
l'esprit que ce regard est
que partiel etc la réalité certainement
beaucoup plus grave cette réalité
c'est la réalité dont une exposition
précoce qui va banaliser le fait
sexuelle cette banalisation du fleix
sexuelle a des effets sur l'enfant et
les effets sur la société
la semaine dernière encore
différents articles sont sortis dans la
presse sur la prostitution des jeunes
filles dès l'âge de 13 ans
13-14 ans des jeunes filles qui sont
recrutés via snap chat via instagram via
tik tok et qui vont
à leur sens ne pas faire la prostitution
mais techniquement soit pratiquée dès ce
qu on appelle des calmes donc être sur
des sites où elles vont réaliser des
actes sexuels devant un public derrière
son écran soit de manière plus triviale
se prostituer au sens propre du terme
cette possibilité pour des enfants
très jeunes 13 ans ça reste quand même
jaune
accepté de faire cela démontre qu'il ya
une banalisation du fait sexuelle que
finalement cela n'a rien d'exceptionnel
et que c'est assez courant en tous les
cas beaucoup plus courant que ce que
nous nous nous pensons et certainement
encore beaucoup moins enfin de manière
beaucoup plus éloigné de ce que les
parents de ces enfants en pense il y a
donc à notre sens un lien quand même
assez manifeste entre la précocité de
l'exposition à la pornographie la
banalisation des contenus
pornographiques
une certaine accoutumance voir
dépendance à ces contenus est une
reproduction dans le monde réel de ce
qui est vu sur les sites pornographiques
il y a de plus en plus mes camarades
parler de l'aggravation de la situation
si on s'intéresse aux différentes
affaires pénales qui touche les mineurs
on constate qu'il y a de plus en plus de
problèmes de viol en réunion
filmé dans les cours de récréation dans
les toilettes de l'école chez des
enfants de 13 ans 12 ans et il est bien
évident qu'ils n'ont pas eu cette idée
tout seul qu'il reproduise un acte qui
l'ont qui l'ont vu en ligne il ya donc
un effet direct
de la digue du visionnage et contenus
pornographiques dans le comportement des
enfants
7 et j'ajoute que plus il y as
accoutumance au contenu pornographique
plus les producteurs le contenu
pornographique ont besoin pour maintenir
cette accoutumance de créer du nouveau
contenu donc de créer en quantité mais
également en qualité alors une fois le
terme qualité aux censeurs les sondages
c'est à dire que plus on est habitué à
quelque chose plus cette chose nous
paraît assez anodine et donc il va y
avoir une aggravation
des pratiques qui vont être filmés
c'est un petit peu comme la drogue
puisqu'il ya une logique de dépendances
si vous êtes habitués une drogue douce
et que cette drogue douce nous fait plus
d'effet donc pas c'est une drogue plus
durer ainsi tout ce qui explique
qu'aujourd'hui on est des vidéos qu'ils
soient de plus en plus hard
et ce qui implique d'ailleurs des
problèmes de respect du droit des femmes
on a actuellement quelques acteurs
pornographiques français qui sont
poursuivis au pénal pour des actes de
viols durant les tournages
essentiellement dans les pays de l'est
ce qui pose la question enfin l'impact
de voiliers se fait même à l'intérieur
du monde pornographiques notamment pour
les actrices mais j'imagine que les
différentes actrices que vous avez
auditionné ont dû revenir sur ce point
notre association n'est pas une
association de terrain dans le sens où
les associations comme comme celle de
mes camarades interviennent déjà sur le
terrain et le font très bien nous nous
avons cherché à nous intéresser à la
cause c'est à dire la diffusion illicite
de contenus illicites
la diffusion est illicite j'y reviendrai
après j'aurai juste
insister sur le caractère bien souvent
illicites des contenus diffusés ces
contenus diffusés sur des plateformes
qui ont besoin d'une quantité importante
ce sont des contenus contrefaits donc
avec une violation du droit d'auteur
pour dire égard
aux problèmes de viol la violation du
droit d'auteur est peut-être moins
graves mais bon c'est en soi un contenu
contrefait donc c'est un contenu
illicite ce contenu est également
illicites dans bien des cas par la
violence qu'ils diffusent la violence
sur les actrices notamment violences
dont elles n'ont pas à laquelle elles
n'ont pas forcément consenti donc on a
un problème de consentement aux actes
qui sont filmés et on a également un
problème de consentement à là diffusion
notamment dans tout ce qui est
pornographie amateurs vous avez
auditionné
robin d'angelo qui a fait un très beau
très belle synthèse des pratiques qui
ont lieu dans le milieu amateur
vous avez quand même des femmes qui pour
200 euros vont pendant deux jours
réaliser un certain nombre de vidéos qui
seront diffusés de manière la plus large
possible et pour 200 euros ces femmes en
ont leur vie ruinée mais vous avez
quelques avocats qui essaient
désespérément de faire retirer ses
contenus donc il y à une réalité
comment dire assez crue de deux de ses
contenus et c'est en ce joli qu'ils sont
illicites ils sont diffusés d'ailleurs
avec un consentement qui est le dans 95%
des cas vicié les contenus sont
illicites et les diffusions et illicite
elle est illicite puisque l'article
227-24 du code pénal est on ne peut plus
explicite
il s'agit qu'un contenu ne puisse être
susceptible début
c'est à dire que le contenu ne doit pas
être accessibles potentiellement par
aucun enfin ne doit être accessible
potentiellement par aucun mineur on ne
peut pas faire une formulation plus
strictes et plus rigoureuse
or on sait que tous les sites diffusent
dans une manière qui rendent cette
diffusion susceptibles d'être accessible
aux mineurs donc la diffusion et dans
tous les cas il y cite l'article 227-24
du code pénal
et
et on ne peut plus claire et j'y
reviendrai après sur le problème du 10
les moeurs
c'est un pass est un sujet qui
pourrait spécifier droit du numérique
est une évidence depuis depuis les
années 2000 je me souviens d'un article
du professeur lepage sur le sujet on ne
peut pas avoir une diffusion qui soit
licite de ses contenus
en matière de numérique s'impose la loi
pour la confiance dans l'économie
numérique de 2004 qui est le cadre
restrictif
des poursuites qui peuvent être engagées
en ligne néanmoins les articles
l'article 227-24 du code pénal
s'applique de plein droit
la lcn n'a fait que créer un régime de
responsabilité allégée pour certains
opérateurs d'internet responsabilités
allégées by responsabilité et pas
absence de respect et par responsabilité
allégée pour d'autres opérateurs il y a
donc en ligne de possibilités
poursuivre au pénal ou poursuivre au
civil la poursuite au pénal est en
général
réalisé par le ministère public dont la
mission je le rappelle
est la protection de l'ordre public
s'avère qu'aucun parquet nous poursuit
les sites pornographiques aucun parquet
ne poursuivez site pornographique alors
même que des plaintes sont régulièrement
déposer notre association a déposé
plusieurs
il y a de ce point de vue là un vrai
problème le civil en revanche offert des
solutions plus efficaces
nous avons eu quelques succès en
réussissant à faire
bloquer des références et certains sites
mais j'ai revenir après il y a encore
quelques améliorations possibles avant
la loi du 30 juillet 2020 comme je vous
le disais l'article 227-24 permettait
d'agir elle permettait cet article
permettait d'agir tant aux associations
en tant que représentant des victimes
qu'au parquet le parquet pouvant agir à
la fois au pénal est à la fois aux
civils c'est à dire que un procureur
peut demander le blocage et le
déréférencement
ce qui a été fait par exemple pour le
site démocratie parce yves participative
qui était poursuivi pour des actes
d'antisémitisme ça a été fait aussi pour
le site argh j'arrive pas le prononcer
mais pour un problème de révisionnisme
donc les parquets peuvent et savent agir
au civil pour faire bloquer et des
références et des sites
ces poursuites peuvent être au fond ce
qui est toujours un peu compliqué ou en
urgence qui correspond plutôt à notre
situation c'est à dire pour faire cesser
un trouble manifestement illicite
et comme je le disais la fermeture de
certains sites par la voie civile
démontre l'efficacité de de cette voie
et en toute hypothèse on a du mal à
connaître l'éventuelle efficacité de
l'autre voie puisque aucune action n'a
été mené au pénal la loi du 30 juillet
2020 a donc imposé un disclaimer donc
pardon n'a pas besoin d'y croire a dit
qu un disclaimer n'était pas suffisant
et a donné une certaine compétence au
président de l'art comme alors comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure avant
cette loi la formulation de la loi
227-24 était largement suffisante
on peut néanmoins se satisfaire que
évidemment
la représentation nationale soit
satisfait se soit mobilisée sur ce point
avec cette loi à travers ce nouvel
alinéa de l'article 227-24 démontre la
volonté de réguler ces sites
pornographiques
pour dans l'intérêt juridique est très
limité quant à la compétence du
président de l'art comme là encore on
peut se satisfaire et ont satisfait du
fait que les pouvoirs publics se soit
investie de cette question pour autant
la procédure mise en place est pour le
moins discutable
en effet selon le la loi du 30 juillet
2020 le président de l'art comme ne peut
poursuivre donc c'est à dire ne peut
demander une blocage wade référencement
d'un site qui après avoir mis en demeure
ce site
autrement dit si je fais un parallèle
vous avez quelqu'un qui dealent au coin
de la rue et vous avez le mettre en
demeure d'arrêter de deals et sinon vous
appellerez la police
c'est la même chose
sachant que la loi de salalah lcn permet
de déjà de demander le blocage et le
déréférencement par voie non judiciaire
le lard com est allé plus loin puisque
si je prends
le la mise en demeure du 7 avril dernier
est la transe elle a écrit aux sites
diffusant des contenus pornographiques
en lui demandant de formuler des
observations donc ça c'est pas prévu par
la loi
les observations n'ayant pas été jugée
satisfaisante
l'art comme a mises en demeure et là
selon la loi il il faut encore attendre
15 jours pour que le site formule les
observations les observations n'étant
pas encore jugée suffisante on agit
devant le président du tribunal
judiciaire de paris sire que déjà la
mise en demeure par et c'est discutable
et l'art comme est allé plus loin en
faisant deux mises en demeure
l'infraction je le rappelle est
manifeste et caractérisée
vous allez sur n'importe quel site
pornographique que qui ont été visés par
l'art comme
le l'infraction est caractérisée il n'y
a pas de problème donc on se demande
dans quelle mesure
il ne serait pas possible d'offrir à
l'art comme une voie d'action plus
efficace
comme je vous le disais en outre la loi
ne permet alors comme que de demander le
blocage et le déférencement par voie
judiciaire or selon l'article 6-1
de la lcn
les prestataires de services pardon les
prestataires de recherche et les
hébergeurs doivent
rendre inaccessible un contenu dont ils
ont connaissance du caractère illicite
donc il serait plutôt souhaitable que
l'art comme déjà avant d'agir au
judiciaire en une mise en demeure aux
prestataires techniques de rendre
inaccessible site et cela permettrait de
vérifier la bonne ou la mauvaise foi des
moteurs de recherche et les fournisseurs
d'accès à internet d'un point de vue
technique procédurales j'ajoute que la
loi du 24 août 2021 à modifier la loi
pour la confiance dans l'économie
numérique notamment son article 6 1 8 en
substituant à la procédure des requêtes
la procédure accélérée au fond alors
cessé de lab c'est du charabia de
juriste mais ça change quelque chose la
procédure
par voie de requête est une procédure
conservatoire non contradictoire qui
permet d'obtenir une décision de blocage
ou du déréférencement
en l'absence de
d'identification notamment de la partie
adverse donc pour tous les sites dont on
ne veut pas d'autres dont on n'arrive
pas à obtenir l'identité ou qui ne
répondent pas c'est une voix tout à fait
efficace et une voie rapide en plus et
non onéreuse
alors que la procédure accélérée au fond
qu'à l'ancienne voie des référés suppose
la réunion de toutes les parties un
débat contradictoire devant le juge une
mise en délibéré pour obtenir une
éventuelle décision donc là encore on a
un allongement des délais et je vous
rappelle que durant tout ce délai tous
ces délais de procédure les contenus
sont toujours accessibles et visibles
par les mineurs
dont mes camarades ont rappelé
l'aggravation de la situation
alors c'est très pessimiste un vieux
comme ça
si on essaie de réfléchir à ce qui
pourrait être mieux
le gouvernement a fait le choix
finalement de confier à l'art comme le
rôle du ministère public on aurait pu
imaginer une autre solution aurait pays
on aurait pu imaginer la création d'un
parquet numérique on aurait pu imaginer
d instruction confiée au ministère
public par voie de circulaire général
comme le permet la loi en insistant les
parquets à poursuivre les sites
pornographiques
tel n'a pas été le choix du gouvernement
et on en prend en en prenant acte on
peut réfléchir à la manière d'améliorer
la procédure
offerte au président de l'art comme pour
faire bloquer ou des références et ses
sites on pourrait notamment comme je
vous le disais simplifier les délais
d'une part d'autre part
explicitement prévoir que déjà des
agents de l'art comme soit assermenté
pour faire les constats pour accélérer
et d'ailleurs réduire les coûts dès
constatation d'infraction
d'un point de vue procédural on pourra
aussi faciliter la possibilité pour les
associations d'agir en justice en
modifiant éventuellement l'article 2-3
du code de procédure pénale et en
clarifiant les discussions doctrinales
et jurisprudentielles autour de
l'article 31 du code de procédure civile
il faut garder à l'esprit
que l'on ne fera pas fermer tous ses
sites ces sites
un intérêt financier tel qu il ne semble
pas possible que du jour au lendemain
ils ferment ce qui à notre sens semble
essentiel c'est réduire le flux réduire
l'accessibilité
car le fait qu'un enfant de 16 ans tombe
sur un contenu pornographique ce n'est
pas la même chose que le fait qu'un
enfant de 10 ans tombe sur ce contenu
et donc plus tard arrivera là je la
première exposition plus tard arrivera
la banalisation plus tard arrivera
l'accoutumance
comment parler olivier il a eu la
réduction du flux est problématique car
de nouveaux outils existent type
instant d'éviter des vpn or monsieur le
sénateur je m'entendais recherché ce qu
est un vpn un vpn c'est un logiciel qui
vous permet de modifier votre adresse ip
est notamment de d'accéder à des
contenus qui ne sont pas accessibles en
france titre personnel voyez ça me sert
à regarder la télé italienne
de manière tout à fait légale parce que
la rai ne diffuse pas en france
les vpn sont
ne sont pas absolues il ya des vpn qui
ne fonctionne pas vous prime vidéo par
exemple sait détecter les vpn et vous
empêcher d'utiliser un vpn pour regarder
une vidéo qui ne peut pas être regardé
en france donc car dans l'esprit que des
solutions techniques existent et à n'en
pas douter les prestataires du les
prestataires techniques
qui a rang général de la de la
possibilité ou la difficulté technique
sont quand même les plus au courant de
ces solutions et j'ai du mal à croire
qu'un fournisseur d'accès en france où
un moteur de recherche
mondialement connu n'arrive pas à
détecter un vpn et a
empêché son utilisation pour accéder à
un contenu pornographique tout cela
suppose
une volonté
politique qui s'est exprimée mais qui
doit trouver finalement une clé
transmission plus efficace d'un point de
vue juridique
nous nous sommes très attachés au
recours judiciaires qui est le garant
des libertés publiques et notamment des
libertés individuelles et il s'agit donc
d'améliorer au maximum la procédure on
aurait pu choisir une autre solution le
gouvernement a choisi l'art comme
essayons d'améliorer les outils à
disposition de l'art comme pour réduire
les délais et qu'à chaque fois qu'un
site soit identifié comme diffusant un
contenu pornographique sans prendre des
mesures drastiques pour empêcher son
accès aux plus jeunes que ce site soit
bloquée et rendu inaccessible dans les
délais les plus brefs je remercie
bien écouter merci monsieur choisel pour
la vie que vous avez donnée sur les
différentes évolutions aussi de la loi
ces derniers mois ces dernières années
je vais je pense immédiatement passé la
parole au sénateur ou sénatrice qui le
souhaitent et peut-être en priorité à
madame la rapporteure laurence rossignol
qui à mes côtés en salle rené monory
merci madame le président chara nique
bonjour d'abord toutes mes excuses à
thomas rohmer d'être arrivé en retard
mais je peux pas être là avant 14h30
donc voila mais bon j'ai depuis
longtemps de vo2 aux deux collègues et
je regrette mais ne pas vous avoir
écouté sa part la pelouse entendre bien
on aura un compte rendu que c'est moi
j'ai pas beaucoup de questions à vous
poser à cette étape on commence à avoir
quand même une
mois qu'on travaille qu'on nous dit on
commence à voir une si ce n'est les des
pros des projets clairs au moins un
diagnostic un état des lieux voilà
sisley un état des lieux assez clair on
peut échanger un peu moi je crois que je
pense aujourd'hui que la question du
porno et d'accès d'accès au porno sur
internet et la face immergée d'un énorme
paquebot qu'on a devant nous qu'est la
question plus globalement des deux des
réseaux sociaux est d'à part que prend
cette activité extrêmement lucrative
dans les activités humaines et même dans
les importants ce fan d'affluence que ça
sur les comportements humains et plus on
avance plus j'avance plus je pense que
la question du lac s'est démis heures au
port neuf à une vidéo porno est en fait
le bon moyen de t'accrocher le pinta
d'accrocher le pignon et l'intérêt sur
le sujet ce que je sache haut que tout
le monde que les mineurs puissent
regarder du porno forte heureusement
mais quitte à passer pour une moraliste
ça me choque tout autant des adultes
passent des lieux en tirant regardé et
je considère que tout ce que vous dites
sur les mineurs qu'est-ce qui nous a
interdit de dire sur les adultes
quand vous disiez tout à l'heure en
monsieur gérard que non c'est vous c'est
vous peut-être monsieur josé de pardon
que
l'accoutumance et la consommation et
puis la différence entre la consommation
moyenne à la consommation médiane et
puis le taux élevé de consommation
importante chez une partie aussi des
mineurs a un impact sur alors falloir
représentation mais aussi leur rapport à
la sexualité
qu'est ce qui nous autorise à penser que
ça ne compte que ce qu'on ne vienne dire
là n'aurait de sens que concernant les
mineurs et les enfants bien entendu ça
un impact aussi sur les adultes et
de manière plus générale système début
de mon propos c'est effectivement la
sphère émergée de l'iceberg
oui merci je pensais pas dix mille
acheteurs immergée de l'iceberg d'un
sujet beaucoup beaucoup plus vaste
sur lequel on nous notre travail intègre
la question de l'accès des mineurs à la
pornographie mais ne s'arrête pas là on
étudie aussi pourtant d'évoquer un tout
à l'heure les contenus
les infractions pénales liées à la
produisent la réalisation des contenus à
la pour contenu au contenu en tant que
test à dire propagation incitation à la
haine raciale 1 station à la hausse etc
cisma la lesbophobie l'homophobie
tout cela tout cela et dans tous les
contenus y compris que ce que quelqu'un
sait que le consommateur soit les du
tout aux mineurs donc on travaille aussi
sur tout ça et sur la légitimité en fait
dans
de ce pc cette idée forte et demi ce que
sam tout l'accès à la pornographie fait
partie des libertés individuelles que
nos démocraties théo garantir à bon
je n'en suis pas je n'en suis plus
totalement convaincu aujourd'hui puisque
par ailleurs l earth d'autres droits
fondamentaux
qui sont des valeurs tout aussi
importante que la liberté de
commerce à nous-mêmes verte et du
commerce et d'industrie peut-être
création voilà bref on a un énorme
chantier devant nous
dès lors que on prend appui sur la
question de l'accès des mineurs la
pornographie je voulais peut-être sur
une terre monsieur gérard tout est réel
et plus largement à l'unaf que vous avez
on sait tous que l'on juge du katif et
ça marche aussi pour le laboratoire
l'observatoire et qu' il ya un enjeu
éducatif sur l'éducation au numérique
mais un autre enjeu éducatif qui est
celui d'éducation à la sexualité
que dans la consommation je crois que
c'est quelqu'un qui vous a précédé à ces
tribunes quel vd c'est une façon cette
une
c'est une curiosité scène à laquelle on
retrouve des outils de réponse malsain
mais
on sait vous avez renvoyé sur les sites
et ses séquelles mais dans le sujet
c'est celui de l'école
voilà pour cette audition au sénat sur
l'exposition de nos enfants au contenu
pornographique une audition réalisée par
la délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat qui continue son travail sur les
violences dans le monde de l'industrie
pornographique voilà c'est la fin de
cette émission en direct du sénat si
vous souhaitez revoir cette audition et
bien vous pouvez aller sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr ou également sur
la chaîne youtube de public sénat je
vous souhaite une très bonne journée sur
public sénat
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
l'actualité parlementaire et politique
continue sur publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
la dîmière poutine son obsession secrète
replacer la russie au coeur de
l'échiquier mondial
il va pas fort et vite thiery europe de
l'est afrique l'ukraine les terrains de
chasse où les coups tactiques de poutine
prennent par surprise un occident
désunis poutine le retour de l'ours dans
la danse samedi à 21h sur public sénat
[Musique]
c'est la frontière orientale de l'union
européenne
à bord de ce vol militaire des
parlementaires roumains et français en
route vers constanta sur les bords de la
mer noire
à quelques encablures de la frontière
avec l'ukraine la base aérienne 57 de
l'armée de l'air roumaine
[Musique]
elle abrite les forces de l'otan
déployées au lendemain de l'attaqué
russe en ukraine
[Musique]
vous voyez
christian cambon et le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense du sénat
il est venu rendre visite aux soldats
français stationnés à constanta
je vais passer par les petits et petits
chemins de ma mère c'est le plus rapide
500 chasseurs alpins qui font partie de
la force de réaction rapide de l'otan
projeté en roumanie dès le début des
frappes russe en ukraine
donné effet le mali lie à la confemen
on enchaîne
j'ai tenu à venir sur place pour voir un
peu d'abord les conditions voir dans
quelle
dans quelle organisation l'été place et
puis vous dire notre confiance quand
même parce que on est à moi je me sens
un peu responsable du fait que vous êtes
là on voit que les crédits on donne
l'autorisation la prolongation et tout
donc c'est n'importe quoi on soit vous
souhaitez
voilà ici en fait il trop mon équipement
mon casque mon art moment
lourds légers avec mon gilet combat ici
il me dit qu'ils savaient que de trois
éléments intérieurs 5
tonnes de denrées à contenir 48 heures
je sais que dallaire coûtant près on
sait jamais ce qui peut se passer une
fois qu'on est déclenchée bas juste à
prendre le sac l'armement les éléments
produits par
ces soldats ne sont pas en exercice mais
en opération
la guerre fait rage à moins de 200 km
ils se tiennent prêts à intervenir en
cas d'escaladé avec la russie
[Musique]
on est sur le parking des véhicules du
bataillon 250 véhicules français ben oui
composée aussi de 300 soldats belges le
bataillon est spécialisée dans la lutte
anti char
donc là vous avez un vab un véhicule de
l'avant blindé donc on est huit à
l'intérieur on a un pilote à l'avant
avec un radio tireur et ensuite le chef
de groupe avec ses hommes qui sont
équipés de mmp missiles moyenne portée
[Musique]
schouten farguettes ça vous tirez vos
acquis la cible est à lier le tireur
derrière une caméra dans missile peut
continuer à l'abri à piloter son missile
le mettre en action finale et il sent
première mission pour moi c'était de
rassurer la nos alliés qui sont sur le
flanc oriental de l'europe et de l'otan
ça c'était la première mission deuxième
mission maintenant c'est d'avoir une
posture dissuasive
et d'être en mesure de défendre ce
territoire si la situation s'envenimer
il ya des scénarios passif non se
prépare si vous voulez à recevoir des
attaques indirectes de l'autre côté de
la frontière donc ça c'est défense
passive on est prêt à subir une attaque
chimique ou nucléaire en suisse il
fallait je désire avoir une action
offensive où se porter à la frontière on
s'intègre dans des plans de défense qui
existent on les améliore et on serait
partis les zones si vous voulez du
territoire à partir desquels on pourrait
intervenir la présence française est
parti pour durer à constanta aux côtés
des militaires roumains italiens
britanniques ou américains présents sur
la base la france devrait prendre le
commandement d'une force de mille hommes
la construction d'un camp en dur est sur
le point de débuter
on est là pour sécuriser aux cas qui
n'est pas improbable car je crois qu'il
faut rester extrêmement vigilant en
étant que nous connaissons au cas où il
y aurait soit des provocations soit pire
encore
l'otan montre ses muscles sur son flanc
oriental
une présence qui rassure la population
en roumanie comme dans cette
manifestation contre la guerre devant
l'ambassade russe à bucarest la capitale
[Applaudissements]
où est notre pays fait partie de l'union
européenne de l'otan
cela représente une barrière très forte
contre tout autre pays qui
envisageraient de nous attaquer
certes protégé par le bouclier de l'otan
les roumains se sentent plus que jamais
concerné par le sort des ukrainiens ils
affichent leur solidarité à l'image de
yann août l'un des organisateurs de la
manifestation
ces noms voisins
ce sont des gens comme nous
ce sont des gens qui qui était de chez
eux tout calmé il ne faisait rien à
personne et maintenant ils sont en
guerre ils meurent chaque jour et les
familles sont cassés quoi